maintenant j'ai accueilli gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
la
nagui m'a dit vas y enfin moi j'admire
vraiment je
fais en fait quand même partie de france
c'est une chaîne dont je salue les choix
stratégiques
non à taratata c'était c'était bien
c'était bien mais franchement un duo
entre david bowie et placez vous ça
quand même vachement moins de clasquin
live de sophia aram qua
non parce que cette année france 2 en
termes de programmation c ça met une
claque à tout le monde
surtout à ses animateurs maison c'est
pas vous être chassé pas sofia c'est
plus une claque c'est une lapidation
moi je savais pas qu al qaïda produisait
des émissions aux études
cela dit je trouve très courageux de
bosser pour le service public
être soumis à la loi de l'audimat tout
en ayant des salaires de la fonction
publique
alors
je ne vais pas parler que la télévision
parce qu'on a aussi des invités un peu
quand on a la chance d'avoir marie
noëlle ce soir sur le plateau c'est ben
je suis votre champion là le président
camarades social-démocrate au beach
non mais en fait il s'en fout un peu de
vos demandes 1 j'ai eu l'impression il a
mis montebourg pour faire le cake devant
les chaînes de montage mais enfin bon
choix précis un moulin à vent savez
relancer le pouvoir d'achat se saurait
quand je dis rien et j'ai suivi une
intervention du camarade hollande alors
dimanche qu'il a découvert que la france
souffrait d'un ras-le-bol fiscal est
incroyable c'est comme un chirurgien qui
opère sans anesthésie il va voir le
patient lui disent 1 c'est dû faire mal
le plus inquiétant si vous laissez moi
je ne comprends pas ce qui dit fin au
temps avant les élections ben je
comprenais l'ennemi c'est la finance je
n'aime pas les riches sarkozy les
méchants ça me parle j'ai acquiesce on
fire
mais mais mais mais là c'est devenu le
gérard majax du brouillard fiscale quoi
vos cheveux c'est la transfiguration le
discours de taddeï dans le corps de
cyril hanouna
alors non mais les gens les gens et de
l'alpa gouët mais monsieur hollande mon
pouvoir d'achat alors lui il est là il
répond j'ai entendu cette préoccupation
et je veux y apporter une réponse
sur la fiscalité ce qu'on va faire cette
année c'est qu'avec la décote du crédit
d'impôt dans l'hypothèse où on augmente
la csg 2% il va prendre 1 99 pour pas
compliqué et en tenant compte d'une
croissance de la dépense publique gelé
dans son poing d'un disent de façon à ce
qu'elles ne dépassent pas le plafond
supérieur du barème il sera rétrocédée à
tous les contribuables je dis bien tous
les contribuables c'est à dire même ceux
dont le quotient familial représente un
delta de 12 si on prend pour référentiel
le temps de maturation d'une fine de
claire numéro 6
il sera rétrocédé le quart de l'impôt
qui devaient être perçus sur une moyenne
des cinq dernières années
[Applaudissements]
et bien sûr je le dis dans une hypothèse
d'inflation à 1,4 156%
mensualisés c'est à dire pour simplifier
racine carrée dit
alors l'autre et moi mais ça veut dire
quoi pour meurtre est
pour la retraite c'est pareil
bon c'est simple l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation qui va être compensé
par un conte pénibilité indexé sur le
tiers payant de votre mutuelle calculé
sur un base du prix au détail de la côte
de porc
du radis selon les saisons k je veux
aussi tenir compte des difficultés que
connaissent nos exportateurs pour
l'évêque
enfin moi je l'entends parler je me dis
mais là en fait il il vient de mettre de
la vaseline ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
là mais je pense que s'il n'y a pas de
concept et contestation sociale violente
en ce moment c'est pas parce que les
réformes sont banon mais c'est parce que
personne ne comprend
[Applaudissements]
bling-bling is back ah oui à l'indécence
est de retour en france qui sont les
français qui sont les français c'est la
crise et les gens se mobilisent pour un
bijoutier
moi ce qui m'impressionne chez les
braqueurs de bijoutiers c'est leur
rapidité pour choisir les bijoux
ils savent tout juste ce qu'ils veulent
comment une fois j'ai regardé un
braquage j'ai dit à ma copine vas-y
prend de la graine quoi franchement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après après on dit que le type c'est un
récidiviste
on le sait bien le goût des belles
choses ça se construit pas en une nuit
alors évidemment la famille du braqueur
dit qu'elle a confiance en la justice tu
m'étonnes quoi c'est normal après 14
récidive toujours en liberté
non mais il ya beaucoup d'inepties sur
ce sujet beaucoup ont dit que c'est un
truc réactionnaire 1,5 million de
personnes qui i like
c'est quand même vachement rare que des
réseaux d'extrême droite soutiennent un
mec qui s'appelle turc
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que 1.5
millions $ en une semaine ça va donner
des idées de buzz certains quoi il
paraît que depuis le phénomène des
bijouteries dans le sud ouest on a déjà
vu françois bayrou rôder près des
bijouteries de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dassault a alors il a acheté les voix
des gens pour se faire élire à corbeil
essonnes il faut comprendre aussi à son
âge il tente le tout pour le tout se
faire élire maire de corbeil et essayer
de faire acheter des rafales à sa police
municipale
il ya un brad may renom mais un
porte-avions c'est bon c'est calais quoi
déplacement cahuzac veut qu'on lui
rembourse ses frais de déplacement pour
les auditions de la commission des
finances ah ben oui un billet de train
plein d'essence il est con aussi quoi il
aurait refusé de venir il aurait eu un
transport gratuit voitures sirènes
escorte et tout le toutim
planaire
perpignan un peu de sous le soleil il
enlève son ex compagne là bas l'an terre
et se dénonce
c'est un peu court
franchement il aurait commencé par la
fin ils avaient l'après midi libre pour
faire la planche à voile
[Applaudissements]
alors on va terminer par la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'il faut quand même
être de l'espoir et de la confiance
parce que sans ça n'y a pas de
croissance à dsk retrouvé un job un a
conseillé le gouvernement serbe pour
redresser la situation économique locale
alors ça n'a pas dû être très difficile
de le convaincre lui a dit vous venez
ici c'est un grand bordel
alors
le monde
d'ici là demain à 15 heures 15
musicales et bien sûr chacun a pu ce
point est à des corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu